[Music]
in should have known better news [ __ ] no
[ __ ] it should know better what but but
submitted by the Kiwis oh I like the QE
I don't really get it it's a those New
Zealand dog is out where Kiwis come from
I don't know but they're really dope
they got a bird and a fruit braid don't
fly a woman who just got hired was
quickly fired from NASA after her
hilarious tweets so funny
so we please thought it was the same day
like she's like they're like you're
hired and welcome she's like oh [ __ ] she
sang on his thumb shut mm-hmm pretty
much oh by the way she's a furry which
makes it even funnier yeah yeah she goes
to work in those clothes that'll be
where she'll live in hilarious I can't
wait till the day where they go don't
discriminate my culture and then they
couldn't come and come in in the furry
costume it's very anything but sexual or
is only sexual or is it not sexual I
don't know from what I hear it is
actually very sexual they have safe bone
and full-on mascot a costume blah oh
snap that was because he's not sure to
get called out all right fine I'll tell
you the truth no I was researching after
JK news what furry stuff was and I saw
this comic and it was like it was like
Han tire hentai porn yeah yeah it was
like this cartoon though right like
tentacle like yeah yeah I got like a
thing to date women exactly my tentacles
and then I just I just read this story
about these two like wolves in the
[ __ ] forest they were like bad human
bodies though they stand on Tuesday
pipette pipette are we in a cartoon
world or a family it's a it's a cartoon
furry world and it's a furry cartoon
like it's I guess it's what it is
and they're in defeat to we're just
throwing every fetish you know just so
imagine like buff ass wolves and like
hot body like like the Egyptians like
oh yeah you like that like that like
that less badass yeah oh and more firm
there's just a straight-up story of them
in the forest and then but then like
then you turn the next page and up who
has like a hard ass dick and like I did
a cumin dick or dog day it's a human
being and then like and then they're
[ __ ] ya know why did they get Pikachu
what does that have to do with you
explain for Eastham yeah because he
looked it up that's he was confessing
that's like you almost spilled this
coffee
that's what furry is this is his
confessions I mean I get it but so far
it is sexual purely yeah pretty much not
purely like its theme where they get
into the furry costume and [ __ ] each
other they have straight-up convention
yeah oh I know I hear stories about
conventions is it like a big orgy why
are people just enjoy doing it like
cosplay right yeah that's what I was
wondering if it's just like I'm into I
don't know that much I just researched
the sexual side of it kind of like ASMR
went from the first time I heard of it
it was a sexual thing oh really
I loved it just cuz of slime I don't
think it's a SM more sexual some people
use it to calm down no like the first
time I ever heard in the sexual context
and I'm sorry
all you didn't hear it in like the
relaxing context I always thought it was
a thing so I thought it was like that
[ __ ] freaks and the people I can listen
to like is tickling my mic nobody is
doing that [ __ ] for real like you're
forcing it don't do that
they make a lot of money on twitch
though all right guys the furries named
Naomi so she tweets everyone shut the
[ __ ] up I got accepted for a NASA
internship hi shut the [ __ ] up that's
why I was talking on Twitter so dude
[ __ ] you bro
language Homer yeah oh [ __ ] him [ __ ]
right yeah that's a boss yeah who is it
oh no does everyone looked at me some I
[ __ ] him anyway though I got accepted I
was lonely so Homer he is an author of
Vietnam veteran and a previous like NASA
engineer still a little [ __ ] don't
scream the first Japanese astronaut so
he responded why is he following her
dumb ass on Twitch or on Twitter I think
I'm popped up because she put NASA yeah
so anyway she responds - suck my dick
and she is her life is over though
[ __ ] it's so pretentious piece of
[ __ ] dude he responds and I am on the
National Space Camp I mention it I love
it I love it I love it when people just
go off like oh well [ __ ] you you don't
know anything about my clever bit of
book she's making coffee she's an intern
she's out there like in outer space
he's on Mars like someone writing
language and then even [ __ ] put a
period yeah those are the kind of people
that don't belong on such a [ __ ] yeah
proper grammar and like discipline
didn't understand how Twitter works
that's for sure the way he wrote
language is also like this
Langly like that [ __ ] guy like the
guy you want to punch language I like
her reply to him it was very pro-life
she's seeking citizenship somewhere else
now life in America is done yes there's
a rap I just wish I could have seen her
face when she read that Jazeera [ __ ] you
know what I am so sorry I want to see
that [ __ ] in her furry costume in her
furry costume inside the cluster
that's how this is gonna go full circle
he's a furry too and they're gonna meet
at a convention and you're gonna become
best friends they're gonna go off of the
sunset now that's a movie Elinor but she
still doesn't have her NASA job no no
yeah they're responding to this and like
retweeting and saying like how is NASA
gonna hire an intern that doesn't even
know who Homer Hickam is he sounds like
a legend if he's an astronaut that
trains other nations astronauts I knew
you were someone just by his twitter
name if your twitter name is you're like
full name like that you're legit okay
Homer Hickman was his at night that's
serious cuz her twitter looks like some
troll twitter
it's not even her face it's like what's
her username something underscore so now
you owe me eight underscore official
furry bushy tail six nine six time it
came out that she lost her internship
she got fired
she's an intern yeah peep on her side
like other phrase like shut the [ __ ] up
Homer you little [ __ ] [ __ ] out the
hashtag [ __ ] man [ __ ] the Navy - that's
so funny that's the stupidest thing ever
that's the internet viral and this yep
[ __ ] you in your [ __ ] mood I like it
on earth anyways we don't need to go out
there [ __ ] you in your Rockets NASA was
the person they'd be really sad if NASA
was a person they'd be Homer Hickman I'm
not turn off the satellites to all of
your phones right now all these guys are
fun you furries can't watch for porn
anymore I'm not even going to tell you
when that meteors coming either be where
I cost bifel massive because they're
tweeters we never took my big old bean
last is the [ __ ] DMV working with
long as they start their own hashtag
[ __ ] furry Homer you wrote a blog post
and says it recently I was called to my
attention on Twitter that someone was
being hired by NASA and that they were
using the f-word in a tweet about it I'm
a Vietnam vet and not at all offended by
the F word however when I saw net you
literally just said language yeah so he
explains that are you offended at knives
I when I saw NASA and the word used
together it occurred to me that this
young person might get in trouble if not
necess I and so I tweeted over one word
language and intended to leave it at
that
soon her friends took umbrage and said a
lot of things but long after I was
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
taking care of everything I'm pretty
guilty of that too because sometimes
people are like you know because you
know how I am on Twitter like I love you
every once in a while you get sweet you
know it's not very ladylike to cuss men
don't like that and I won't like suck my
dick [ __ ] [ __ ] and then it was Obama
appropriate I used to run your country
[ __ ] you not anymore [ __ ] 48:46 I
don't know anyway so then he continues
as I immediately deleted my comments and
blocked all concerned later I learned
she had lost her offer for an internship
with NASA this had nothing to do with
nor could I since I do not hire and fire
at the agency or have any say on
employment whatsoever as it turned out
it was rumor the NASA hashtag her
friends used that called the agency's
attention to it so she's an influencer
she reached out to me with an
unnecessary apology which I heartedly
accepted and returned with my own after
talking to her I am certain she deserves
a position in the aerospace industry and
I'm doing all I can to secure her one
that will be boys
I have also talked to the folks that had
to do with their internship and made an
absolute made absolutely certain that
there will be no black mark on her
record that's really nice over it's
great they said her friends treat Frank
disease hashtag but he obviously doesn't
know her Twitter works yeah that's
probably not her friends no I got
anybody get Throwdown a hashtag and be
on team furry well I mean I guess that's
a easier way than saying like people are
responding to the tweet I think he's
lost in the sauce
no biggie understands yeah I would just
say people hashtag yeah but even so an
ass's part that's lame if they didn't
mind what she did but they were just mad
what her friends did offends got her in
trouble yeah if I get fired cuz it was
brought to their attention because the
hashtag mess up so it was her tweet what
a cool guy like after someone said suck
my dick and my balls he's like you know
what I think they still deserve an
internship the funny thing is she didn't
even have a job she had an offer for an
internship that was pulled away it's an
offer day of that's ridiculous hashtag
love homered it made me love all Vietnam
vets that much more I just feel like
they're so down for anything
it's like suck my dick and my balls and
for them that's like Oh dudes brains
blown out when I was in Nam so whatever
a few sudden big balls it's fine it's
funny how like dudes went through some
crazy [ __ ] like that and when they
become old they're more proper but
you've probably seen some [ __ ] they're
also a super traditional man then I
wonder if they were like correcting each
other even on the battlefield let's kill
these [ __ ] gooks just say gooks
don't say [ __ ] gooks the word was the
fact that they were used together he
could have explained it I mean we all
kind of took the language yeah
[Music]